in Sweden in they are gonna test out
something that is very
on American they want to see it working
less
well actually increase productivity
that's right the city government
Gothenburg Sweden
want to test the impact of shorter hours
and how that affects productivity in an
experiment
that begins in about three weeks so one
group government workers in the elderly
care sector are gonna work six hours a
day
while another organ worked for eight
hours that their custom to working
after a year the government is going to
analyze the results and decide whether
the six-hour day
actually a allows people to accomplish
just as much as they were doing with two
extra hours
a course proponents of cutting the work
they are saying that you know people
have fewer
sick but the sick days and they'll be
more efficient in general
I and be international productivity
ranking by Conference Board
a non-profit business research
organization sweden was already
close to the top coming out 11 61
countries in terms of productivity
and we've got more info on that Korea
so it is average work hours and
international productivity ranking
okay so we can see here is that in the
Netherlands they don't work at time but
they're ranked fifth in productivity
pretty good
the United States we do work a lot an
average of would be roughly 400 more
hours a year than they do in the
Netherlands and we are predicted he's
pretty good
interestingly in Chile and in Mexico
they worked her son
and their productivity is not good so
there's also order
it a little all over the place but also
I think you can get some
interesting stuff from it so it let's
just start with the the american
components were in america here
this is a very un-american right to say
oh you should work
or less and maybe that made me more
because we're just taught to work
and work and work to withdraw on working
hard working
Mart so I player if you're tired and
you're hating life
yeah you're gonna work much more poorly
so I kinda
think think we didn't have a point here
yeah should we jump on this bandwagon
that's weird because I think when they
do that once they get the information
back on this legacy yeah
people can work more nimbly and more
swiftly
I think it it would be a great thing a
people work fewer hours because we were
good time a lot alike people are
independent contractors nowadays is one
there working more than 40 50 60 hours
we have a lot of young
lawyers that are going crazy 100 120
hour week work weeks
I think that unacceptable but I think
that if we are gonna lower the minimum
number of hours for full time work
from the a to fix we also have to make
some changes so that
workers are engaged or getting the same
level of productivity
we know that certain activity that work
lead
to you know lead to resultant others
don't so that's where we should focus
our energy making people happy are more
engaged at work
so arts let's talk about happy because
we never talk about that right
that that the one thing that never
talked about at is
the relation between work it happened so
they've done studies that show that
people that are working are generally
happier because then you have money and
you can go do things and take vacations
and things like that
but we don't really talk about it and so
do the day-to-day basis like where
happiness is coming from people I'm sure
that are working 100 hour work weeks
I know that happy right now like your
family you're not sleeping enough you
know eating enough nothing a friend you
know getting things done that you need
to get done that already been fun at all
yeah of course you're stressed out do
you guys think that as the economy
changes and now that we can do
everything online in computers and
things like that that you can accomplish
as much in three hours as maybe they
used to be able to accomplish
all day long so the I so I feel like a
lot of people right now
people are watching they're allowed to
be watching this at work we know it. a
lot of our videos are watched during
work hours
and people are at work without things to
do you actually because its order the
old paradigm
a like working nine to five but actually
you can accomplish all you need to do
from Mike nine to 11 this idea working
to like from 925 come from like the
the times on agriculture when we had to
wake up at a certain time
and then there was light and so we used
up all the valuable light time and then
we went to bed after the sunset or
whatever
so it makes no sense to apply to like
today is
society where we have artificial light
where we have the Internet where we can
communicate globally
I think that what's happening though is
that because we have all these
technological advances
would want people to do more and yeah
bother they expect more out of us like
now like
I know and so many my friends tell me my
boss sent me an email at three o'clock
in the morning
an expected to respond to light up
Buckingham output is inevitable that you
get emails about our don't you
records I see it all the time I get
emails I we got my check mail it in the
morning like
head out any other 10 or on the weekends
and get the expected response them like
fuck this like this is not OK
yet so is that the huge drawback to the
technology because now they're saying
how
in how people don't even stop working
when they're on vacation now because
everyone has
and iPhone and you can literally yeah on
the beach you're like oh shit
you know I bad yeah I love them
people like from work like a for
I different date now or
no but yeah I can definitely see this a
I feel like most of the work day is
spent you know hurry up and wait for
wasting time running out the clock
ever need to be that way we can enjoy
our lives shockingly enough and we can
enjoy our work
also talking we know yet so it's sweet
in which already as we said they
they don't work as much as us and they
are more productive if they find this to
be true and really push this idea all
over the country
do you think they're gonna have an
immigration problem I'm pretty sure
pretty sure they don't have the easiest
the immigration policies in the first
place but really you think this will be
the place we would be like you know what
they're doing something right here
different though to know they're very
much focused on education much more than
you know the US is and also how fear
they have a better educational system
they have about
better health systems I think those two
things also highly contribute to their
productivity
not just about the hours the fact that
they have a society where
even if they're working fewer hours or
so working great there you go